A
NOW.
>> I SEE YOU HAVE ANOTHER
THROWBACK SHIRT ON.
HOW ARE YOU GETTING THESE LOOKS?
WHO IS HELPING YOU GET THEM?
>> WE ARE JUST FINDING THEM.
YOU GO OUTSIDE, YOU GO DOWN THE
STREET, YOU GO SNAG THEM UP.
I'M JUST PAYING MY DUES.
THIS IS A BASKETBALL TOWN.
THESE GUYS HAVE PUT IN THE WORK
OR THE ARENA TO BE AS LOUD AS IT
WAS LAST NIGHT.
I APPRECIATE EVERYONE FOR MAKING
THIS ORGANIZATION WHAT IT IS.
>> I REMEMBER AFTER ONE OF THE
CLIPPERS GAMES, YOU WERE
REMINISCING ABOUT EARLY IN THE
SEASON WHEN MONTY SAID YOU HAVE
THE WORST STARTING FIVE IN THE
LEAGUE.
YOU SAID YOU SAT DOWN IN TALKED
ABOUT THINGS.
WHAT DO YOU REMEMBER ABOUT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND WHAT YOU GUYS
FIGURED OUT.
HOW QUICKLY DID YOU FIGURE IT
OUT?
>> HE SAT DOWN, IT WAS NOT JUST
ME AND CHRIS, WE WERE REALLY
HONEST WITH EACH OTHER.
I ALWAYS SAY WE HANG OUR HAT ON
THE INCIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT THE CONVERSATION
WAS.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT CHEMISTRY
ON THE OFFENSIVE AND.
IF WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
SCORING, THE OTHER TEAM CANNOT
BE SCORING.
ALL OF THOSE MOMENTS ARE WHY WE
ARE IN THE POSITION WE ARE IN
RIGHT NOW.
WE STILL HAVE TO GET THE JOB
DONE.
>> ARE YOU ASKING YOUR DAD ABOUT
THE GUYS ON THE SHIRTS?
>> HE WAS WITH ALL OF THESE
GUYS.
I'VE DONE MY RESEARCH.
>> THE SHIRT LOOKS A LOT NEWER
THAN WHAT IT SHOWED.
>> I HAVE DONE MY RESEARCH.
>> I AM CURIOUS ABOUT FINDING
ROLES.
WHAT DID YOU START TO SEE IN
YOURSELF AND OTHER GUYS?
>> I TALKED ABOUT THAT EAST
COAST ROAD TRIP.
THAT WAS A HEAVY HITTER LINEUP
FOR US.
WE CAME TOGETHER.
MORE THAN EVER.
WE WILL ALL HAVE TO SACRIFICE
SOMETHING.
>> MONTY HAS BEEN PRAISING YOU
RECENTLY.
WHAT DO YOU RECALL ABOUT THAT
MEETING?
>> WE WENT TO DINNER AND WE WERE
TALKING.
I TOLD HIM WHATEVER IT TAKES.
I HAVE NEVER HAD A PROBLEM WITH
ANY COACH.
LET ME KNOW WHAT I HAVE TO DO.
I WILL GO DO THAT TO THE BEST OF
MY ABILITY.
I THINK THAT WAS THE START OF US
FORMING THIS ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE
BEEN IN.
UNDERSTANDING WHERE WE COME FROM
AS PLAYERS.
THAT IS WHAT WE LIVE ON.
THE ENERGY AND THE CULTURE WE
ARE AROUND.
>> YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT KOBE A
LOT AND THE IMPACT HE HAS HAD A
NEW.
WHO WAS IT FOR YOU WHO PLAYED A
PART IN SHAPING YOUR GAME?
>> RIP HAMILTON.
I ACTUALLY GOT THE CHANCE WHEN I
BROKE MY NOSE TO HAVE A SHORT
CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
WE HAVE TALKED IN THE PAST.
THAT WAS MY CHILDHOOD HERO.
THAT IS AN INSPIRATION FOR ME.
JUST LOOKING AT THEM ON THE
SIDELINE.
THERE ARE TONS OF GUYS.
>> PHOENIX HAS A LARGE LATINO
POPULATION.
I AM WONDERING WHAT THAT HAS
BEEN LIKE FOR YOU WITH YOUR
BACKGROUND >> I AM AROUND EVERY
DAY.
I AM FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
AROUND IT.
GROWING UP IN MICHIGAN, YOU
DON'T GET AS MUCH OF IT.
THAT MAKES THIS MUCH BETTER.
>> CONGRATULATIONS ON THE NBA
CARES AWARD.
WHAT IS IT LIKE TO SEE
EVERYTHING COME TO FRUITION?
>> THAT IS MY FAVORITE PART.
I DON'T CARE FOR MUCH
RECOGNITION OR ANYTHING.
I DON'T DO IT FOR THE
RECOGNITION.
IT MEANS A LOT TO THIS
COMMUNITY.
THAT IS WHAT WE GET THE MOST
EXCITED ABOUT.
FOR THE FOUNDATION TO WIN THAT
AWARD IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
>> YOU NEVER SCORED 20 AT
KENTUCKY.
THE ONLY HAD 10 SHOT ATTEMPTS
FOUR TIMES.
YOU GOT 70 IN A GAME.
IT'D CAUSE YOU ANY DOUBT BACK IN
COLLEGE?
>> NO.
EVERY GREAT TEAM HAS TO HAVE
SACRIFICES.
A TEAM THAT TALENTED, THAT MANY
GUYS, TO MAKE IT WORK AS WELL AS
COACH DAVID -- DID, IT WAS
INCREDIBLE.
I REMEMBER PRACTICES WHERE HE
WOULD SHOOT A THREE AND COACH
WOULD LOSE HIS MIND.
NOW HE IS A 40% SHOOTER.
JUST UNDERSTANDING THAT.
WHAT CAN I DO TO HELP THIS TEAM
WIN?
THAT WAS MY ROLE.
IT GOT US IN THE POSITION TO BE
WHERE WE NEEDED TO GO.
>> DOES THAT APPLY TO THE TALENT
OF THIS GROUP?
>> YES.
THERE ARE GUYS SACRIFICING.
THAT IS ALL OF US.
EVERYBODY CAN PLAY.
EVEN THE GUYS WHO ARE PLAYING.
THEY WOULD PLAY ON ANY OTHER
TEAM.
THEY ARE STILL A BIG PART OF HOW
WE CONTINUE TO GROW IN GET
BETTER.